I killed a woman the other night.
I didn't feel any guilt
or remorse.
I just felt...
Empty.
Is that how you feel?
No.
People aren't who you think they are.
They're someone else too.
Someone you don't get to see.
What's going on?
It's cop stuff, sweetheart.
You weren't supposed to kill her.
I don't know what to tell you. It wasn't my fault.
Nobody steals from the cartel.
You caused this. You'll work it off.
I can't do that.
Are you in trouble?
I don't really feel like talking about it.
Do you trust him?
Yes.
Good.
Because I see beautiful things in him.
Society's falling.
It's all collapsing around us.
Soon our cities will be washed away by floods,
buried in sand,
burned to the ground.
That's why you found me.
As the world fractures
someone has to be there to protect innocence.
I want the worst guys you got.